[Music]
other questions that I get very often
for instance from women in my audience
what we're the best what are the best
locations for female travelers who are
traveling alone and the fact the matter
is everywhere I have gone I have met
women who are travelling along and
having a great time
but you should use of course common
sense and certain cities are simply more
violent or have more violent crime than
others and you want to do your homework
this is particularly can be particularly
problematic in places that are can be
super fun but where you have extreme
wealth and extreme poverty bordering
each other for instance in Rio in Brazil
very very common in many of the cities
of Brazil this is super common and there
can be quite a bit friction between
those two sides and you just want to be
aware of that looking at the State
Department websites and looking for any
type of tourism advisory issues or it's
always a good idea before I had to take
a look at all of them but if you are
good at planning and also good at
improvising and you make an effort to
learn the native language this is
another thing use something like the
link word method or you could look at
people like Benny Lewis the Irish
polyglot who has a lot of good tips for
language learning pick up at least 50 to
100 words in the language where you are
going you can do it on the plane right
over it's not hard look up a link word
method and which is effectively a
mnemonic method that allows you to turn
sounds and the images very easy you
could you can easily learn 50 to 100
words on your way over and that will
dramatically not dramatically in a
binary fashion turn your trip from from
enjoyable to incredible because everyone
will respond to you differently this is
particularly true in locations where
most tourists do not make an effort like
Japan as one example and last but not
least if you're traveling with your
family I've been traveling with my
parents for instance every six months or
so there are certain cities that are
very very
walkable and have a high density of
impressive things per square mile or
kilometer Paris is one such example it
is by far the most beautiful city I've
ever been in Bar None just walking
around and everything catches your eye
as absolutely spectacular and you can do
it relatively inexpensively surprisingly
enough there are neighborhoods where you
can do that and it doesn't require miles
and miles of walking if your parents
have health issues or fatigue issues and
so on so I'd be another one that I would
put on the list of must visits if you
have the opportunity but the world is
your oyster there are many other options
and I could give you easily another 20
that I'm just as excited about but those
are a few of the highlights and happy
travels
be safe be curious be respectful and
think that will get you a long long way
you